welcome back everyone we are counting
down to the opening of resorts world the
first brand new property on the strip in
over a decade
yeah so the grand opening is going to be
a big deal it's tomorrow night there's a
lot of excitement about the business the
resort will bring to las vegas
in addition to all the other stuff this
morning we are live inside for the first
time at resorts world
bianca holman is there with a sneak peek
bianca good morning to you
hey good morning john good morning alex
so i am inside the high limit the high
roller room
and yeah you can find me in here i may
not be betting of my own coins but
somebody's money is getting used to bet
on
black right here but this is going to be
an amazing room it just screams luxury
take a look across here
we know that conventions are a huge part
of our economy
and again all those convention goers
were right across the street they will
come here to the high roller room
and spend some coins but the resort has
more than 250
thousand square feet of event space it's
also less than a half a mile from the
new convention center expansion
that means resorts world is uniquely
placed to attract people in town for
conventions
but also it will host shows right inside
as well
there's going to be a lot of competition
just because of where we are now i think
business travel across the country if
not across the world is really
getting back on speed what is critical
here is that many of these conventions
are big right they are bigger than one
facility having additional space
allows them to have city-wide activation
so resorts world also has six ballrooms
which we know can double as event space
for
exhibitors and plenty of space for major
events so again this is a phenomenal
property we've just been blown away
from the lobby to the casino floor to
the sportsbook
the restaurant road that we got there
some famous street eats and look at this
louie pup
i can take him home right i need this in
my living room
well you can come check it out when they
finally open tomorrow we know it's going
to be a huge grand
weekend grand party tomorrow and we got
you covered so
tune in keep it locked to channel 8
because we're going to show you an
inside look
all the way until tomorrow it's going to
be amazing you guys back to you in the
studio
so wait a second bianca you're going to
bet with other people's money and you're
going to take the louis vuitton dog with
you
yes okay yes i mean is there any other
way
john i'm not i'm not complaining come
over here so i can use some of your
coins
you got some money for me to spend she
said
i mean i'm good luck remember yeah
good luck that is true i i don't
complain about that all right
lady luck here i'll join you and we can
spend john's money
thanks yes it's gonna be very good it's
gonna be a very short time at the table
if that happens
thanks bianca thanks all right so you
can now book a room with your own money
at resorts world
not john's there are three hotel towers
each has something different
there are ultra luxurious villas and
palaces over at crockford's
the conrad has its own private reception
lobby and vip check-in
and the hilton features a classic stay
with city and strip views
that you're going to see that people are
going to stay maybe at the hilton the
first time and then they're going to say
wow let's experience the conrad and
that's how we look at it when we combine
the brands in
in such a impressive resort like this
so rates this weekend range between 460
and
560 a night thursday's grand opening
includes some private events followed by
public ceremonies
you can officially step inside around 11
o'clock
tomorrow night john it's going to be
exciting yeah